[Music]
on this tuesday night inside the rubble
of a ukrainian mall obliterated by
russia they like killed people the
desperate search for survivors and pleas
for peace our sean o'shea is at the
scene breaking news about british
columbia's premier john horgan's sudden
announcement about his resignation
stunning testimony about donald trump
the president said something to the
effect of
i'm the effing president
taking me up to the capitol now what he
allegedly did inside the presidential
limo on january 6th
and reaching for the moon again nasa's
high hopes for a return visit
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie good
evening thanks for joining us top
officials including prime minister
justin trudeau are in madrid tonight
ahead of the nato summit there they're
united in their support for ukraine
galvanized following russia's deadly
attack on a shopping mall in the central
part of the country crews continue to
dig through what's left of the mall in
the city of cremenchuk hit by a russian
missile late yesterday at least 18
people are dead more than 60 have been
injured our sean o'shea was inside the
skeleton of the building today and has
our top story tonight from ukraine with
more on the search for survivors
security video shows the moment of
impact the shock wave sends a man in the
water at a neighboring park a shopping
mall has just been attacked
fire engulfs the largest mall in the
ukrainian city authorities say a
thousand shoppers have been inside when
they say an air-launched x-22 cruise
missile struck the building some people
got out to safety after hearing a
warning alarm others were not so
fortunate
rescue crews moved in as quickly as
possible within hours ukraine's
president addressed the attack
russia's strike on the mall is one of
the most daring terrorist attacks in the
history of europe said vladimir zelinski
ukrainian authorities put out a table
displayed pieces they say are from the
attacking missile
the attack took place as members of the
g7 met in germany you could feel the
whole mood of the meeting become yet
more
somber we condemn these attacks and our
hearts go out to the victims and their
loved ones it's important that the world
doesn't lose its attention and focus
over what's happening in ukraine
the morning after the attack the search
continued inside the mall
this is something you wouldn't see in
canada journalists have been allowed to
come into the rescue area and you can
see firefighters behind us using their
hands to pick through the rubble they're
looking for bodies
search dogs joined the effort too
russia's foreign minister denied what
happened instead claiming russia's
missile successfully hit a hangar
storing weapons and ammunition nearby
a russian military spokesperson wrongly
claimed that that hangar detonated a
non-functioning shopping center but
that's not true war crimes prosecutors
have been pouring over the scene sizing
up their latest case against russia one
described the kremlin's intentions this
way they like kill people actually we
see that they like shelling
houses
hospitals some ukrainians living here
say they have to keep fighting what
would be your message to russians today
please stop rest
want to live in peace
across the street from the mall
other businesses are patching up from
the collateral damage they sustained and
people like anna are simply at a loss
for words to describe what this latest
attack means to them never never words
just feelings and
it's like
it's too much for everything of us does
it hurt
yes this attack is now the country's
highest profile war crimes investigation
a focal point for what russia is doing
to civilians sean shea global news
kremen chuck ukraine
prime minister trudeau announced new
financial support for ukraine at the
conclusion of the g7 summit in germany
this morning canada will provide 152
million dollars in new money for
humanitarian security and development
purposes canada will also loan the
country 200 million dollars for urgent
financial obligations trudeau traveled
to spain this afternoon ahead of the
nato summit in madrid international
diplomacy was well at work before the
summit turkey is agreeing to support the
membership bid of finland and sweden
after the three countries reached a deal
to address turkey's security concerns
david aiken is traveling with the prime
minister and tells us why this meeting
of world leaders could be the most
consequential of them all
prime minister justin trudeau is in
spain for his fourth and final summit of
world leaders in as many weeks in this
one a meeting of nato heads of
government is shaping up to be the most
consequential of them all nato leaders
arrived ready to chart a new course for
the 73 year old alliance by finalizing a
new strategic concept its most
significant shift since the cold war it
will address china for the first time
and the challenges that beijing poses to
our security
interests and values but the most
pressing threat right now of course is
russia nato leaders are expected to
approve plans to beef up defenses on the
eastern or russia-facing flank of the
alliance and they'll discuss how to
boost the nato rapid response force from
forty thousand personnel to a whopping
three hundred thousand
but it's not clear how much capacity
canada has to help
new figures published by nato itself
showed that defense spending in canada
measured in constant dollars dropped by
three percent last year compared to the
year before and over the last five years
defense spending by canada has been
shrinking by an average of one percent
each year canada is always
part of nato missions and continues to
step up significantly
canadians expect to do that as to do
that in a responsible
and
reflective way but back home even
trudeau's top general has not been able
to say where he's getting a promised 4.9
billion dollar boost for continental
defense i can't say definitive
definitively where it's coming from and
the prime minister tuesday offered
little precision these are extremely
important investments that we've made
they are fully sourced now using the
arguably flawed measure of defense
spending as a percentage of a country's
gdp
nato said this week that canada this
year will spend
1.27 percent of its gdp on defense
that is the lowest level since 2016 and
compared to all the 29 other members of
the nato alliance that's good enough for
canada to be in
24th place
ahead of slovenia and luxembourg colleen
david aiken in madrid thanks david
breaking news out of british columbia
john horgan is stepping down as premier
of the province after weeks of
speculation horgan made the announcement
this afternoon saying he's not able to
make another six-year commitment to the
job
it's
not a secret that i have gone through
my second boat of cancer and uh
successfully went through 35 radiation
treatments and our and i am currently
cancer free my health is good but my
energy
flags as the days go by global's richard
sussman joins us from victoria richard
this is the end of the road for one of
the country's most popular premiers
it sure is colleen and he will remain on
until the ndp chooses a new leader so
that will be in the fall but it did come
as a big surprise that horrigan decided
today to announce the resignation
especially considering in less than two
weeks time he will be welcoming premiers
from across the country here to victoria
to debate health care transfers and to
try to put pressure on the federal
government to get more health funding
for all of the provinces but horgan says
he did not want this conversation around
his future to be a distraction around
the decision on health care and the
other important measures his government
is working on here right now including
housing affordability so horgan
ultimately conceded that today was the
right day to announce he would be
stepping down moving aside to continue
to focus on those core priorities and
hope that ottawa will give one last
feather in his cap with some additional
money for health care for all canadians
colleen back to you richard zusman and
victoria thanks richard
breaking news near victoria bc global
news has confirmed six police officers
have been injured during an exchange of
gunfire near a bank
police say they responded to a report of
armed suspects at a bank of montreal in
the community of saanich five officers
were shot while a sixth suffered unknown
injuries two suspects have been killed
the search for a possible third suspect
is ongoing and nearby homes and
businesses are being evacuated due to
the threat of a possible explosive
device
in the united states stunning new
testimony took center stage at the
january 6th committee hearings in
washington today a former aide in donald
trump's white house shared a behind the
scenes look at the chaos taking place
within the administration and the
demands from the former president to let
his people in as the violent
insurrection took place on the capitol
in 2021 jackson proskow was following
the hearings for us today jackson
colleen the revelations came from
cassidy hutchinson a former aide to
trump's chief of staff she was in the
room during many of these key moments on
and before the 6th hutchinson described
trump's rally outside the white house on
the morning of the 6th saying the secret
service had warned that people in the
crowd were armed and they were actually
confiscating weapons at security
checkpoints trump allegedly demanded
that security be loosened in part so
that he could grow the crowd outside the
white house for the cameras
i was in the vicinity of a conversation
where i overheard the president say
something to the effect of you know i
don't even care that they have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing mags away
let my people in they can march the
capital from here let the people in
we also learned that trump personally
wanted to join the mob in the march to
the capitol to interrupt the election
certification and when the secret
service wouldn't let him travel to the
capitol building he apparently became
enraged inside the presidential limo
the president said something to the
effect of i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now the
president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
jackson if trump knew the mob was
violent had weapons and didn't intervene
to stop it did he commit a crime
well no doubt that question is being
asked inside the justice department
right now remember they're investigating
seditious conspiracy charges against
several extremist groups the question
does that link directly back to trump or
the white house the committee today also
warned that there have been several
attempts from trump's inner circle to
intimidate the witnesses they're
currently interviewing colleen
jackson prosco in washington jackson
thank you
at least 50 deaths have now been linked
to a tragic discovery near the
texas-mexico border late last night
we're not supposed to open up a truck
and see
stacks of bodies in there
none of us come to work imagining that
the bodies were found in the back of a
tractor-trailer on a remote back road in
rural san antonio in what's presumed to
be a migrant smuggling attempt more than
a dozen survivors including children
were taken to hospital as eric sorenson
reports the tragedy comes as border
authorities struggle with a surge of
attempted crossings
this tractor-trailer supposed to be a
gateway to a new life became a
sweltering coffin for dozens of migrants
a horrific human tragedy individuals
who are no longer with us
who had families
who were
likely trying to find
a better life
it is from poverty and desperation said
mexico's president speaking of the
hondurans guatemalans and mexicans
identified among the dead so far the sad
reality is the deaths in texas are but
one tragedy in a resurgent humanitarian
crisis
tens of thousands of migrants are on the
move toward the united states in 2020
the first year of the pandemic fewer
than 50 000 migrants per month were
stopped crossing the u.s border the
numbers spiked last year to 200 000 and
in 2022 record numbers in may alone 239
000 so-called border encounters in the
southwestern u.s it is human misfortune
with no easy political solution
president biden is faulted by
republicans for having open borders but
experts in migration say the crisis
stems from governments denying migrants
a proper refugee process so they resort
to desperate tactics to sneak in it
becomes a job creation program for
smugglers
and it makes crossing entering
more dangerous in canada the number of
so-called irregular migrants has been
small quarterly figures in the low
hundreds during the worst of covet 19
but in the first three months of this
year the numbers jumped to over 2700 and
while ottawa has vowed to take in 4 000
refugees from the americas by 2028 it
will hardly make a dent in the mass
migration it's important to remember
that 85 of the world's refugees are
actually
hosted by countries in the global south
not by countries like the united states
or indeed canada
god willing the united states says this
colombian migrant we want a better
future but the reality that awaits them
is often dire and sometimes deadly eric
sorensen global news toronto
long covet has long left doctors and
patients puzzled coming up what canadian
researchers have just discovered
as covert 19 cases and hospitalizations
begin to wane across canada there are
still thousands of people suffering the
effects months even years after
infection scientists are trying to
unravel the mystery known as long covid
and now as jamie morocco reports
canadian researchers may have found a
key clue
olympic gold medalist alex kopach is
used to being out of breath behind his
bobsled but last year when the then 31
year old caught covet he felt his breath
taken away like never before i was in
hospital for
five days
i was having oxygen
for about
once it was almost almost two months it
took about four months after he was
released kobach says before he could
breathe normally again at western
university scientists are now a step
closer to figuring out why so these
people look normal clinically and their
chess cts were also
quite normal lead researcher grace
porrega and her team used a special mri
five times more sensitive than a ct scan
to zoom in on kopach's airways what we
found was that exchange of oxygen from
the air and the alveoli into the red
blood cells was abnormally low red blood
cells are responsible for the
transportation of oxygen from your lungs
to the rest of your body any disruption
in this flow triggers your brain to
command the lungs to breathe more
resulting in a feeling of breathlessness
of 34 unvaccinated participants in
western study only 12 of them who had
been hospitalized by covid all had the
same abnormality
having an identifiable abnormality
that fits with their symptoms
is
satisfying versus everybody
you know being labeled as somebody who's
suffering from long covet and you know
people telling them it's in their mind
it's a cognitive thing
now researchers hope to understand why
covid is causing this abnormality more
than a year after his vote with the
virus kopachu has recovered hopes
identifying the trigger will lead to
treatments
knowing the severity of some of these
diseases might give us better tools to
work with
the recovery process
shedding light on a disease we still
know very little about jamie marrocker
global news toronto
problems pumped up just ahead the
tightening grip of soaring gas prices
and how to loosen it
by now you don't need us to tell you how
high gas prices are soaring in this
country or why surging costs have forced
many canadians to rethink their summer
plans
that may be a minor inconvenience but as
ann gaviola reports new polling shows
just how far the surging price at the
pumps is driving widespread financial
hardship and straining our daily
routines
yeah it's ridiculous
it's very difficult yeah i don't know
why the prices are this high but
we can't control it summer road trip
season and the return to the office the
surging price of gas couldn't have come
at a worse time you have the food cost
the clothing costs
all of the different things that go into
having go into the office
and including the the inflationary costs
of food whether you're bringing it
yourself or going out for lunch
these are all adding up
for some households it means really
staying put for a staycation for others
it will mean real financial hardship
in new ipsos polling conducted
exclusively for global news nearly 70
percent of respondents said they may not
be able to afford gas anymore that
number includes a whopping 80 percent of
parents with young children and nearly 8
out of 10 young workers aged 18 to 34.
77 of respondents are driving long
distances less about half say they can't
afford to fill up which means more
day-to-day planning gas prices are high
it costs more money
there's plenty of parks to close by so
we can use them lower income households
are least able to afford and manage
sky-high gas prices but there are tried
and true things you can do to make your
gas money go further easing off on the
gas and the brakes when you drive for
example and ditching any extra weight in
your vehicle like winter tires or spares
in the trunk if you can download a gas
app to look for the cheapest gas in your
area i know a lot of people who are
using public transit and walking and
cycling a lot more than they ever were
before as well as just planning their
trips being a little bit more strategic
gas analysts can't say for certain if
there's relief in store this summer it
depends on the war in ukraine and how
damaging the hurricane season south of
the border will be three dollars a liter
seems to be the predominant view
although a lot of people think that it's
gonna go to two dollars a liter as well
but there's very few people who think
that the price of fuel is going to go
down uh in the next little while
either way it's likely to be a crude
awakening
ann gaviola global news toronto
small satellite big hopes the pivotal
role a tiny device plays in our possible
return to the moon next
it has been 50 years since the last
manned mission to the moon but today
nasa took a step towards returning
astronauts to the lunar surface a small
spacecraft was launched from new zealand
as ross lord reports it'll study the
orbit where nasa plans to build a space
station for stops to and from the moon
earth's moon is the only place beyond
our planet where humans have set foot
it's one small step for man
one
diaper
more than a half century later there's a
return in the works
three
two
one it's called the capstone mission
nasa making a new path around the moon
to clear the way for astronauts to
eventually set foot again on its surface
nasa teamed up with two private
companies at a relatively low cost of
about 30 million u.s dollars a satellite
about as big as a microwave oven will
create the new orbit sending crucial
information almost 400 000 kilometers
back to earth if we can set up a base
camp of sorts on the moon we can learn
even more about what it takes for humans
to thrive and survive
on these different and
difficult environments in the near term
there are other moon pursuits including
a canadian company that intends to
support the mining of energy called
helium-3 if you mine that and bring it
here you have good source of renewable
energy without the harm of radioactive
material the moon's weak atmosphere and
lack of liquid water make it impossible
for humans to live there but the
prospects for another visit are coming
more sharply into view
ross lord global news
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada is horseshoe
canyon west of drumheller alberta we
love seeing your canada so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching eric sorenson will
be at the anchor desk tomorrow good
night
[Music]
you